>> Judge Jeanine: AT WELCOME
BACK TO THE "HANNITY."
A PARTIAL GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN
LOOMS OUT OF FRIDAY’S DEADLINE.
HYSTERICS HAVE ALREADY BEGUN.
REPUBLICANS OFFER TO COMPROMISE
ON THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING FOR THE
WALL, BUT THE DEMOCRATS
IMMEDIATELY REJECTED THAT DEAL.
EARLIER TONIGHT, PRESIDENT TRUMP
TWEETED "THE DEMOCRATS ARE
SAYING LOUD AND CLEAR THAT THEY
DO NOT WANT TO BUILD A CONCRETE
WALL, BUT WE ARE NOT BUILDING A
CONCRETE WALL, WE ARE BUILDING
ARTISTICALLY DESIGNED STEEL
SLABS SO THAT YOU CAN EASILY SEE
THROUGH IT.
IT WILL BE BEAUTIFUL.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, GIVE OUR
COUNTRY THE SECURITY THAT OUR
CITIZENS DESERVE.
IT WILL GO UP FAST AND SAVE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS PER MONTH
ONCE COMPLETED.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION, A
FOX NEWS JOHN HURT, AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR DOUG SHOWN.
THE WALL WITH THE BEAUTIFUL
SLATS, ARE YOU QUESTIONING
WHETHER WE WILL GET THAT?
>> I DON’T THINK WE WILL GET THE
WALL.
I THINK WHAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
DONE LAST WEEK WAS A 1.6 BILLION
IN BORDER SECURITY, FUND THE
GOVERNMENT AND MOVE FORWARD.
THIS IS FRANKLY A SETBACK IN
BUILDING THE WALL AND ALSO A
SETBACK FOR DEMOCRACY BECAUSE
THE FACT THAT WE CAN’T FUND THE
GOVERNMENT -- AND I UNDERSTAND
IT’S ONLY A PARTIAL SHUTDOWN
BUT, THIS IS PATHETIC.
>> Judge Jeanine: BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT, THIS ISN’T TRUMP’S FAULT.
BY THE END OF THE DAY, WHAT WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT IS BORDER
SECURITY WHICH HAS BEEN KICKED
DOWN THE ROAD SINCE, ACTUALLY I
THINK 1986.
NOW WE HAVE SCHUMER AND PELOSI
SAYING IT’S NOT HAPPENING.
ARE WE GETTING THE WALL?
>> HERE YOU HAVE A PREVIEW OF
WHAT THE NEXT TWO YEARS WILL BE
LIKE.
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS WE HAD
TEN DEMOCRATS IN STATE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP ONE.
IT WAS IN THEIR INTEREST TO FIND
COMMON GROUND WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
GOING INTO THE 2020 ELECTIONS,
THERE ARE TWO.
DOUG JONES OF ALABAMA AND GARY
PETERS OF MICHIGAN.
THERE ARE LESS DEMOCRATS WILLING
TO WORK WITH THE PRESIDENT ON
BORDER SECURITY, ON HEALTH CARE,
ON THE ECONOMY.
WHY?
BECAUSE IT’S IN THEIR INTEREST
TO OBSTRUCT AND INVESTIGATE, AND
ULTIMATELY SEEK TO IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT.
>> Judge Jeanine: AT THE IDEA
OF THE 1.6 BILLION FROM, I THINK
IT WAS LAST WEEK, THAT THE
DEMOCRATS SHUT DOWN.
NOW WHAT WE HAVE IS SARAH
SANDERS SUGGESTING THERE IS
MONEY FROM OTHER DEPARTMENTS
THAT CAN BE TRANSFERRED SO THAT
HE CAN BUILD THE WALL.
SPECIFICALLY FROM HOMELAND
SECURITY, AND I BELIEVE THE
PENTAGON.
IS THAT VIABLE?
>> I THINK AS YOU TALK TO PEOPLE
THAT HAVE STUDIED THIS FOR A
LONG TIME AND AS YOU POINT OUT,
THIS HAS BEEN A PROBLEM THAT HAS
BEEN KICKED DOWN THE ROAD SINCE
1986.
LAWMAKERS IN WASHINGTON REFUSED
TO FIX THE PROBLEM, AND FUNDING
THE WALL HAS NEVER BEEN A REAL
BIG PROBLEM HERE.
THE REAL PROBLEM IS, THE WILL TO
ACTUALLY DO THE HARD WORK OF
PUTTING UP THE WALL AND TAKING
THOSE VOTES.
THE ONLY THING WE HAVE FOUND OUT
IN THE LAST TWO WEEKS IS
DEMOCRATS THAT ARE COMING INTO
CONTROL OF THE HOUSE AND SENATE
AND CONGRESS HAVE VOWED TO SHUT
THE GOVERNMENT DOWN, INSTEAD OF
DOING SOMETHING ABOUT FIXING THE
BORDER.
WHETHER YOU CALL IT A WALL OR A
FENCE, OR WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
DESCRIBED IT AS THROUGH THESE
TWEETS THAT YOU JUST READ,
WHATEVER YOU CALL IT, IT’S A
BARRIER THAT PREVENTS PEOPLE
FROM ILLEGALLY CROSSING INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
DEMOCRATS HAVE MADE IT VERY
CLEAR THAT THEY ARE ON THE SIDE
OF OPPOSING THAT AND, DEMOCRATS
AND REPUBLICANS HAVE MADE IT
CLEAR THAT THEY ARE ON THE SIDE
OF SUPPORTING IT.
EVEN DEMOCRATS WHO SUPPORTED SAY
THE SAME THING, BUILDING A
THE 2006 FENCE ACT DID BASICALLY
BARRIER WHICH WILL KEEP YOU FROM
SNEAKING INTO THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY.
EVEN A LOT OF THOSE DEMOCRATS
HAVE BEEN PULLED BY THE
LEFT-WING OF THEIR PARTY OVER
INTO THIS NO BORDERS ANTI-I.C.E.
SANCTUARY CITY CROWD WHICH
OPPOSES DOING ANYTHING ABOUT THE
BORDER.
>> Judge Jeanine: THE IDEA OF
A WALL, A SECURE FENCE, SCHUMER,
PELOSI AND OBAMA WERE ALL
SINGING THE CHEERS.
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE NOT STUPID.
THEY ARE IN FAVOR OF A BORDER.
THEY UNDERSTAND WE NEED TO BE A
SOVEREIGN NATION.
THEY ARE SAYING WE ARE GOING TO
OBSTRUCT, WE ARE PROUD TO
OBSTRUCT.
AND THEY ARE ALMOST GOING
AGAINST THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AS
WELL.
>> THERE IS ONE OTHER COMPONENT
MENTIONED, WE HAVE 11 MILLION
PEOPLE HERE ILLEGALLY.
WE NEED A PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP
AND A WALL.
WE NEED BORDER SECURITY AND A
COMPROMISE, AND THAT’S WHAT
POLITICS IS ABOUT WHEN YOU HAVE
A DIVIDED GOVERNMENT WHICH WE
WILL HAVE IN A COUPLE OF WEEKS.